mm-hmm
may I extend a warm welcome to you from
our UK Parliament
we are honored and feel extremely
privileged to have you here today with
us and I hope you know you are indeed
among friends
before you take the floor to give a talk
about a very important subject which is
violence against women during conflict
I'd just like to say a few words
it is only nine months since the second
invasion of your Homeland by Russia
an act of aggression that shocked and
uphold us all but nine months is a long
time
while the UK continues to offer help
supplying military hardware and training
to thousands of UK troops
offering homes to your displaced people
and even an unprecedented platform video
link for your husband president
zielinski to talk to our members in the
House of Commons in the chamber
it is easy for those of us who live in
peace to not want to think about what
you are going through
when there is no end inside people
suffer news fatigue
but just as we must not forget the
Holocaust we cannot deny that is
happening again
we must not sleep walk into thinking
that this is a situation is is going on
in a far away land
that it does not affect us
so your Brave visit with us today
most Shockers awake again you must make
us listen when you say that Ukraine
women are being raped by Russian
soldiers and that the people's lives are
being destroyed children are being
murdered homes are being destroyed you
must make us listen after all we are you
and you are us
we cannot imagine what is happening to
you but how we would feel if this
happened to us
you need to keep going and we need to
keep supporting you because if Putin
wins other nations will be in this site
myself and colleagues many of whom are
sanctioned by Russia raise your plight
at every opportunity
in discussions about food energy
security and the rights of women and
girls of the recent G20 speakers
conference in Jakarta
I was vehement in my attack on Russia
about the rights and your Sovereign
rights
and I've got to say I refuse to sign any
communique that did not acknowledge
Russia as the aggressor
I made no friends
proud of that
so letters in the UK be your continued
voice that your story your liberality of
being invaded does not disappear it is
our duty to keep the spotlight on you to
keep shaking the world away to the
horrors Russia is committing
I know first ladies lenska it's not been
easy for you or your family being
separated during this awful War we know
the sacrifices that you have made to
spread the message of peace and to keep
your family safe
so for you to join us today takes a
level of bravery which is a Hallmark of
your president of your Parliament and
the Ukraine people that and I say I
thank you for being here today and
please first ladies Valencia the floor
is yours thank you
[Applause]
you need me
to come down
anything
this
these are the impressions of the 15 year
old boy of a teenager
this is not a quote of a Ukrainian boy
no this is a lost London Western
teenager
he said that about the events which
happened over 18 years ago
but ukrainians feel the same now the
boys and girls from cave men and women
from nipro karchef zapurisha vineet
salvief
dozens and dozens of Ukrainian cities
which suffer the attacks of the Russian
Blitz
dear ladies and gentlemen Mr Speaker
members of parliament government my
lords
and the great nation of Great Britain
ukrainians are now going through the
terror which will resonate with you
your Island survived the Air Raids which
were identical to those that Russia uses
now to put us on our knees
we're hearing Sirens every day the
identical to those which were hurt by
the British Generations you did not
surrender and we will not surrender but
Victory is not the only thing we need we
need Justice
I came to you for justice
because Justice
will lead to the end of this war just as
it led to the end of the previous war
it was impossible to imagine that after
all the crimes of the Nazi
criminals
the the nonsense will remain unpunished
it was impossible to imagine that the
londoners and the inhabitants of
Coventry Liverpool Birmingham Manchester
or Sheffield
would indeed accept that those
aggressors would avoid the courts and
not be accountable for the terror we are
Imagining the same we we imagine that we
have to do the same
and we need Justice for our people who
suffer from the missiles
as the Nazis assembled hundreds of
aircrafts to turn into horror the
British days and nights Russia is doing
the same with missiles and drones
Iranian drones for the mass missiles
attacks
70 even a hundred missiles a day and
those cities who are on the front line
survive the lethal strikes have a look
what it means
this is a hospital in vilnansk in zapore
region we had the maternity unit there
Russian missile attack
destroyed everything
13 people
managed we managed to save but one newly
born boy who was only two days old was
killed
the next photograph was shared by
thousands of people
the parents of these children had to
find the gas station so that they could
find the electricity the power supply
for her inhaler
she couldn't survive without it that was
during the blackout
during yet another Mass Russian missile
strike more than 20 million ukrainians
remained without electricity water heat
they had no electricity in for over 30
hours in some places this is how it
looked
the doctors were operating in the dark
and the transport stopped and
communication our enemy wants to destroy
the rush of the energy and hit us with
the darkness and cold
we do not know exactly how many boys and
girls
and women and men became the victims of
torture and violence brought by the
Russian occupiers but it's important to
understand that Russia brought the
systematic violence in many the occupied
towns and villages we find the chambers
torture chambers which were organized by
the occupiers we have documented
thousands of crimes including the sexual
violence the youngest girl who was raped
by the Russian occupiers was four years
old the oldest Survivor was 85. these
are the victims we know how many victims
we still don't know about
these are the burnt
blocks of apartment blocks in person
Russian army is
hitting hereson dozens of times a week
planned cruelt accrual attacks and they
are attacking men women buildings
schools and hospitals which would have
been impossible without the orders of
the senior of the leaders of the
terrorist state in the five days in five
days in Houston last week
15
people were killed and this is another
threat to the millions of ukrainians we
are talking about the mines
over 200 000 kilometers of our soil are
now covered in mines and unexploded
munitions
when the occupiers retreat
they are leaving everything around their
mind
quite often they're hiding their minds
and the explosive devisers
say that it would be difficult to find
them straight away in the buildings in
the civilian cars in the critical
interest rate infrastructure for example
in one of the flats in the key region
they mined the piano
that sums it up the attitude not just to
people but to art as well
this is not spontaneous or random mining
this is a criminal policy of the Russian
State the element of aggression and the
attempt to damage and premeditatedly
kill as many people as possible
and these are just some examples of the
countless number of crimes not just from
the 24th of February this year but also
from 2014 when Russia attacked Ukrainian
Crimea and seized it and studied the
hybrid war in donbass all these crimes
against ukrainians and Humanity
are born from one primary primary crime
that is the crime of aggression of
Russia against Ukraine and you and
Russia has to be responsible for this
therefore I'm addressing you ladies and
gentlemen
that's why I'm addressing the United
Kingdom
80 years ago in London not far from this
place where we are now
in the Saint James Palace
the document was signed which helped to
Define history
the war was still going on and nobody
knew what was going to happen but on the
13th of January
1942 the Declaration was signed which
recorded the will
to make accountable those who were the
perpetrators in the war crimes crimes
against humanity and peace that became
the basis of the Nuremberg that's how
that's the way it looked
the Declaration which was recorded and
signed by the future Victors they've
signed
resolved to see to it in a spirit of
international solidarity
but a those guilty responsible whatever
the nationality are sought out
handed over to Justice and judged
and be
that this sentence is pronounced are
carried out
Ukraine Europe and the world need that
type of Justice now and it can be
started in London again
because we know that Justice is one of
the benchmarks of the British way of
life
you have got a powerful experience of
the international law
and defending the values of humanism
that's why we're addressing Britain we
are fighting for justice
but Justice like Victory is not possible
without allies
the president of Ukraine has suggested
our form and and announce our formula of
Peace next day Russia responded with
hundreds of the missiles
but just like in 1942
the replies of Nazis did not matter we
have to understand that together we can
do it with you
unfortunately the international criminal
court which we actively work with does
not have the legal Force
and they can't enforce the punishment
against their primary crime of those who
started the war we need to start the
special tribunal against the crime of
aggression of Russia against against
Ukraine which will enhance the work of
the ICC and not weaken it
we need it to punish those who are
politically and militarily responsible
for the crime of war and Terror this is
the seventh point of our formula of
peace and I hope and believe that
Britain can become the leader of its
implementation
to support this special tribunal we have
prepared if they draw the draft
resolution and this draft resolution of
the general assembly of un should become
the political foundation of the
international efforts to punish the
aggression and Allah I would like to
address you Britain and you ladies and
gentlemen with the request we need to
unite the world Community just as it
happened in January 1942 to support a
special tribunal against the aggression
of Russia against Ukraine I'm asking you
a small favor to become the world leader
in the Justice
efforts
this Justice is not just needed for
Ukraine we need it so that the world
could lead could lead its life not by
the rule of force as their aggressor
wants but following the values of
humanism we need the justice so that the
world could survive
at the moment we can see Terror online
it's obvious
we can see it live with mass documented
evidence of crimes it's easier to find
the proof it's obvious now and I believe
that London can give this impetus
decisive impetus so that the world can
become better very World thanks to you
you know
Justice
thank you
all the way
[Applause]
foreign
thank you for being with us today and as
you can see from the response in the
room I speak for the whole room when I
say how overwhelmed deeply shocked and
moved we are by your speech and the
graphic images which accompany it the
suffering endured by your people is
unacceptable and we are on your side in
that fate for justice
violence including sexual violence
against women and girls during conflict
is a subject too often
not seen or spoken of
yet we know its lasting impact on
survivors their families and indeed
whole communities is devastating
it is felt not only by the current
Generations but those two come for many
years
in highlighting this today you're
inspiring and helping us to raise
awareness not only among the
parliamentarians in the room but with
the people of the United Kingdom
the women of Ukraine have demonstrated
immense bravery from those who have
remained in your country facing the fear
and uncertainty that every day brings
to those who now find themselves in
unfamiliar lands
far from husbands fathers and brothers
with many family units separated and
mothers keeping their children safe and
trying to help them to adjust to what no
child should ever have to do
The Bravery
stoicism and resilience shown by
Ukrainian people especially as your
country heads into a bitter winter
and facing an energy crisis
is truly humbling and inspiring
president zielinska a true leader in his
daily addresses to the Ukrainian people
demonstrating his continued and
determined efforts as well as his
absolute conviction that Ukraine will be
free is an example to the whole world
first lady zolenska before this war
you had said that you were comfortable
to be in the background
to fully support your husband as
president
but not by taking on a major public role
in your own words you were nervous of
making big speeches
and yet here you are today and there you
were in the U.S Congress in July and
there you will be on another Global
stage on another day doing a job you
never wanted and expected but you are
doing that for Ukraine we thank you from
the bottom of our hearts
that first lady
demonstrates resilience and courage
to quote President Roosevelt
courage is not the absence of fear
but rather the assessment that something
else is more important than fear and you
are demonstrating that
please assure the Ukrainian people that
we see you as our neighbors and as such
we stand in solidarity with you as you
continue this fight
we wish you president zorinsky your
family and all European people continued
strength fortitude and successes and you
can be assured in going back to Ukraine
that the messages that we are your
friends United with you in that fight
for justice thank you for your
attendance today we are all humbled by
it
[Applause]